[Musik]
ja das waren zehn sekunden ist er
natürlich was ganz anderes erwartet sie
haben erwartet dass der mann sofort
wieder anfängt mit herzlich willkommen
bei alpha centauri und so weiter und so
weiter
ihre erwartungshaltung war so dass da
jetzt irgend was passieren muss das was
sie gerade gehört haben war ein
zeitintervall von zehn sekunden zeit hat
einstein gesagt zeit ist das was ich mit
der uhr messe bestimmt aber gar nicht
diese zehn sekunden eben die waren ganz
schön lang
das ist schon ungewöhnlich dass jemand
vor der kamera steht und zehn sekunden
lang einfach nur da steht und nichts
macht zehn sekunden auf einer bühne
können für einen schauspieler eine
katastrophe sein weil er eigentlich ja
gerne diesen ganzen text loswerden will
den er gelernt hat also zeit ist was
ganz merkwürdiges wir haben wir in
diversen sendungen schon damit zu tun
heute soll es mal um was ganz spezielles
gehen ich würde sagen unter dem credo
vernunft für wird dogmatiker möchte ich
heute gerne über das thema sprechen was
ist zeit in der speziellen
relativitätstheorie die spezielle
relativitätstheorie kürzlich jetzt ab
mit srt dann kann ich mir das schreiben
wir sparen denn so viel zeit habe ich
mich dass ich das auch noch ausschreibe
und die sr t unterscheidet sich ja von
der ard also nicht ard sondern auch rt
der allgemeinen relativitätstheorie die
spezielle relativitätstheorie ist das
was einstein 1905 als die elektro
dynamik bewegt der körper verkauft hat
also publiziert hat nicht verkauft hat
publiziert worum ging es in der arbeit
es ging um die frage was passiert
eigentlich mit unseren grundbegriffen
von raum und zeit wenn wir uns in
verschiedenen bezugs systemen aufhalten
also es gibt ja verschiedene
möglichkeiten
der existenz möchte ich fast sagen es
gibt die ruhende existenz also keine
bewegung man selber ist in ruhe
im vergleich dazu kann es ein bewegtes
bezugssystem geben zb die
berühmt-berüchtigten züge autos oder
sonst irgendwas es gibt auch bezug
systeme die rotieren die sind dann also
auch nicht offenbar gleichberechtigt
wenn man sich daran erinnert wie man
sich zum beispiel auf einem
kettenkarussell fühlt gleichberechtigt
mit dem system der ruhe oder mit einem
bezug system das sich mit gleichförmiger
geschwindigkeit bewegt die spezielle
relativitätstheorie beschreibt bezugs
systeme die sich mit konstanter
geschwindigkeit relativ zueinander
bewegen
solche bezugssystem nennt man initial
system das heißt jemand der sich mit
konstanter geschwindigkeit relativ zu
einem anderen bezugssystem bewegt der
merkt nichts davon von seiner trägheit
in gewisser weise ist trägheit frei das
heißt die einzige bewegung die er
feststellt ist nun diese konstante
geschwindigkeit und nichts anderes
beschreibt die relativitätstheorie als
die relation gilt also die beziehung von
grundsätzlichen größen zwischen diesen
beiden bezugssystem und hier kommt es
nämlich die kommen nämlich mein credo
vernunft für wirtz dogmatiker die
relativitätstheorie beschreibt nur dann
raum und zeit wenn es mindestens zwei
bezug systeme gibt ja wenn es nur eine
uhr gibt also eine armbanduhr und nur
ein ort gibt also ein bezugssystem gibt
dann macht die relativitätstheorie keine
aussagen vergleicht man uhren
miteinander die im gleichen bezugssystem
sind also die sich mit der gleichen
geschwindigkeit v bewegen oder in ruhe
sind dann macht die relativitätstheorie
die aussage beide uhren gehen gleich
eine frage bewegt sich aber eine uhr nur
mit einer geschwindigkeit von relativ zu
einem ruhenden bezugssystem sind sie
noch da es ist nicht so einfach ich weiß
also noch mal bewegt sich eine uhr nun
relativ zu einem anderen bezugssystem
also relativ zu einer anderen uhr und
man möchte diese beiden miteinander
vergleichen dann
und die relativitätstheorie ins spiel
und da kommt dann auch die zeit ins
spiel
da kommen dann so sätze raus wie bewegte
uhren gehen langsamer tja wie die geht
langsamer gehen doch nicht langsamer
bewegt uhr geht doch nicht langsamer die
macht doch nicht tick tick tick für
denjenigen der sie am arm hat wenn er so
eine laute uhr hätte bei denen vergeht
eine sekunde ganz normal
tick tick tick aber für denjenigen der
in einem anderen bezugssystem diese uhr
beobachtet die sich da von ihm weg
bewegt für den geht diese uhr die sich
bewegt langsam
woran liegt es muss ganz einfach und
schon sind wir wieder bei den
dogmatikern es gibt eine endliche
geschwindigkeit für die ausbreitung von
wirkungen im universum
diese geschwindigkeit nennt man
lichtgeschwindigkeit schneller als licht
geschwindigkeit breitet sich keine
wirkung im universum aus möchte ich also
als ruhen das bezugssystem also als
ruhende uhr etwas darüber erfahren wie
schnell die uhr in einem bewegten
bezugssystem geht bin ich darauf
angewiesen dass diese uhr sich mir
irgendwie mitteilt das geht aber nur
über strahlung elektromagnetische
strahlung zb den lichtblitz ja dieser
lichtblitz also die würdigung die mit
dieser uhr zusammenhängt bewegt sich mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit
und das ist der punkt zeit in der
relativitätstheorie und zwar in der
speziellen relativitätstheorie die sich
mit sozialen systemen beschäftigt mit
bezugssystem die sich mit konstanter
geschwindigkeit relativ zueinander
bewegt die zeit ist ein relativ angabe
weil gleichzeitigkeit eben davon
abhängig ist ob sich jemand bewegt oder
nicht alles hängt nur daran dass es in
diesem universum eine maximale wirkung
ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit gibt an
sonst nichts
das heißt also
je schneller ich eine uhr bewege relativ
zu mir
umso langsamer muss diese uhr gehen
gemäss der speziellen
relativitätstheorie es kommt noch was
anderes hinzu
was übrigens der gleiche effekt ist nur
die jetzt nicht mehr mit zeiten sondern
mit längen bewegte längen also wenn ich
zum beispiel dann starb hätte und ich
würde dir eine bestimmte richtung
bewegen
dann würde dieser starb in
bewegungsrichtung für einen guten
beobachter wenn dieser staat sich auf
ihn zu bewegt dann wird diese länge
kürzer
das nennt man längen kontraktion also
bewegte längen werden kürzer bewegte
zeiten werden länger so könnte man das
sagen bewegte uhren werden länger und
das ist ein interessanter effekt der da
auftaucht denn geschwindigkeit im ganz
allgemein ist ja nun weg brotzeit also
einbruch jetzt könnte man sich überlegen
wir beschleunigen ein lineal auf dem
auch nur befestigt ist auf annähernd
lichtgeschwindigkeit
was muss da gemäß der
relativitätstheorie dabei rauskommen für
einen äußeren beobachter was sieht
was zieht er sieht dass die dass der weg
das ist das lineal selbst immer kürzer
und kürzer und kürzer und kürzer wird
also der zähler des buchs wird immer
kleiner und kleiner und kleiner und
kleiner
gleichzeitig sieht ja dass die zeit die
in diesem system gemessen wird genau auf
dieser uhr immer länger und länger und
länger und länger und länger wird also
daneben da wird immer größer was macht
denn nun ein buch dessen zähler immer
kleiner und dessen nenner immer größer
wird der bruch geht gegen null
das bedeutet mit anderen worten wenn man
sich mit lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen
könnte
als masse behaftetes teilchen dann würde
für einen weder zeit vergehen doch würde
man weg zurücklegen und das ist völlig
in übereinstimmung mit der vorstellung
dass sich im universum eine maximale
wirkung ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit
bemerkbar macht in form der
relativitätstheorie die
relativitätstheorie beschreibt
fundamentale kategorien des daseins
wenn man das mal so ganz pathetisch aus
drücken will zeit ist also in der
relativitätstheorie immer eine relative
größe
das große problem was sich hinter diesem
credo vernunft für wird dogmatiker
verbirgt ist nun dass wir glauben wir
menschen glauben dass die welt so
aufgebaut sein müsste dass sie unsere
anschauung von raum und zeit tatsächlich
auch gehorcht nur ist das natürlich für
uns schlecht möglich ja meine wir haben
geschwindigkeiten
was können wir denn 100 meter läufer
dann macht mal 100 meter wenn das
schnell ist in 10 sekunden
das sind aber keine großen
geschwindigkeiten in zehn sekunden läuft
das licht zehn mal 300.000 kilometer
das heißt die effekte die mit der
ausbreitung von wirkungen verbunden sind
die sind in unserem für unsere
anschauung für unsere
erkenntnisfähigkeit sind die direkt gar
nicht bemerkbar
wir erleben dass nicht wir erleben nicht
das ja eine bewegte uhr von einem
unserer freunde zum beispiel der sich
mit der geschwindigkeit von 150
kilometer pro stunde über die autobahn
bewegt dass die sich nennenswert
langsamer bewegen würde die uhr dass die
sich länger also dass sie langsamer
gehen wird muss ich vorsichtig sein was
wäre das bemerken wir nicht das sind um
messbare phänomene die
relativitätstheorie und in diesem fall
die spezielle relativitätstheorie ist
das allererste mal dass uns eine
naturwissenschaft die wir selbst
betreiben uns mit ergebnissen
konfrontiert die unsere anschauung nicht
mehr zugänglich sind und nun sind
dogmatiker eben der meinung das kann gar
nicht sein
maximale geschwindigkeiten können es
nicht geben es müsse auch über
lichtgeschwindigkeit geben warum weil
ich sie denken kann dann kann ich nur
sagen das können wir vergessen
aus der tatsache dass ich etwas denken
kann folgt noch lange nicht dessen
existenz das hat übrigens kam gesagt ja
also ich kann mir natürlich denken dass
ich tausend euro in der hosentasche
hätte aber davon ist es noch lange nicht
tatsächlich auch der fall
es muss im gegenteil damit ist im
universum überhaupt zu einer kausalen
verbindung von ereignissen kommen kann
immer eine maximale wirkung
ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit geben es
geht da gar nichts und deswegen ist das
mit dem zeitbegriff und auch mit dem
raum begriff in der relativitätstheorie
immer dann wenn man in die nähe der
lichtgeschwindigkeit kommt auf einmal so
problematisch wir verstehen es nicht
mehr auf einmal überlegt man sich ja
meine güte
also wenn sich etwas so schnell bewegt
man denke nur an die expansion des
universums da gibt es ja galaxien die
extrem weit von uns entfernt sind und
die entweder wie soll man sagen die
ihnen die flucht geschwindigkeit dieser
galaxien die ist ja knapp an der
lichtgeschwindigkeit und schon gibt es
also menschen die der meinung sind ja
wenn die sich so schnell bewegen dann
vergeht ja bei denen keine zeit mehr das
plätzen
das einzige was wir sehen ist dass das
licht was von diesen galaxien kommt rot
verschoben ist das heißt die wellenlänge
sind größer geworden die uhr die dort
mit einem bestimmten frequenz verbunden
ist einfach langsamer geworden was
anderes sehen wir nicht aber dort am ort
der galaxie selbst ist eine sekunde
so sieht also die gleiche definition von
einer sekunde haben wir auf der erde
eine sekunde
tick tick tick das ist gar nicht der
fall die uhren da oben die merken gar
nichts davon dass wir sie messen das ist
der punkt es gibt also in der
relativitätstheorie immer nur jeweils
eine uhr für jedes bezugssystem es gibt
keine allgemeine uhr also man kann nicht
demokratisch darüber abstimmen wie viel
uhr es ist wenn man unterschiedliche
geschichten mit unterschiedlichen
geschwindigkeiten sich bewegt allerdings
wie gesagt ist das ein phänomen das nur
dann auftaucht wenn man in der nähe der
lichtgeschwindigkeit ist also wenn die
geschwindigkeit des bezugs systems in
die nähe der lichtgeschwindigkeit kommt
aber noch einmal zurück zu einem zu dem
punkt weshalb ich endlich diese sendung
diesmal mache weil ich bin häufig
angeschrieben worden bieten das sein
könne die uhren müssten doch im
universum früher viel schneller oder
viel langsamer gegangen seien und wie
wir den zeit im universum ausrechnen
können ja wodurch die
relativitätstheorie gesagt dass bewegte
uhren langsamer gehen es geht hier nicht
um eine kosmische uhr insgesamt
es geht immer nur um die uhren in einem
jeweiligen bezugssystem es ist alles nur
dann relativ wenn man möglichkeiten hat
das vergleich
eine uhr alleine ist für die
relativitätstheorie gar kein thema
sondern es müssen immer zwei da sein
also ich hoffe das hat jetzt
einigermaßen klar gemacht dass zeit in
der speziellen relativitätstheorie
wirklich nichts anderes ist als das was
ich mit der uhr messe mit der uhr die an
meinem arm oder in meinem bezugssystem
ist und sonst nichts
in diesem sinne gilt tick tick tick tick
tick tick tick tick
[Musik]